il y a juste trop de choses qui se passent en
même temps et les
gens ressentent la pression maintenant
la pression va être encore
pire
[Musique]
on va prendre une bouillotte et s'asseoir
avec une couverture plutôt que de mettre
le chauffage  de retour parce que mettre une
couche en plus ne coûte rien
alors que mettre ton chauffage va euh
rincer ton compte
en banque  juste derrière mon loyer et je ne
veux pas être expulsé, je vais probablement
devoir me
débrouiller sans chauffage et
faire certaines choses et ne pas utiliser
uniquement le gaz à certains moments et euh
tu sais que je vais  nous devons le faire la
plupart du temps,
nos propres factures d'électricité ont doublé, passant de
170 livres à près de 400 par mois
dans notre bureau et
nous avons du mal à payer cela, donc
je ne peux qu'imaginer ce que ces familles
traversent,
elles changent  éteindre l'électricité
éteindre le
chauffage la nourriture que nous leur donnons
ils ne peuvent pas la cuisiner parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de la cuisiner
même si les salaires et les revenus des prestations
vont augmenter en avril ils
n'augmenteront pas à  le même taux
que les prix et cela signifie qu'en fait,
pour la plupart des gens, ils vont être
moins bien lotis parce que le montant de leurs revenus
n'ira pas aussi loin en termes de
ce qu'ils peuvent acheter avec, donc nous
voyons
un revenu  compression standard et bien sûr
pour ceux qui ont les familles les moins pauvres
ça va être le plus
difficile à gérer cette année
[Musique]
vous